hello everyone the topic of my
presentation is dynamic evolution of
unstable genomes we know that cancer is
known to be the disease of the genome
and genetic alterations under Lattimore
genesis and resistance to therapeutics
also genome instability is known as the
call mark of cancer in this presentation
I want to share with you some of our
recent findings about evolutionary
dynamics of unstable cancer genomes and
how this process might contribute to
tumor development before discussing
cancer genome evolution I want to
briefly revisit the classical model of
tumor Genesis known as clonal expansion
as cells replicates its DNA and divides
into daughter cells errors can occur
resulting in mutations alterations in a
genetic sequence that can be stable II
transmitted into the progeny of the cell
it has also become clear that in
addition to automations in a DNA
sequence alterations such as DNA
methylation and chromatin states can
also lead to a result in change changes
in gene transcription that can be stable
II transmitted individual into the
progeny population as well now if either
by genetic alterations or epigenetic
alterations the cell acquires some
proliferative advantage it can lead to
Colo expansion upon which further
mutations can arise and lead to more
aggressive phenotypes this was the first
model of tumor Genesis proposed by Peter
novo in 1976 originally proposed for the
development of leukemia since then it
has been adopted in many other contexts
and most perhaps best known in a context
of regenerative the development of
colorectal cancer known as Duvall Graham
where the different phenotypes and
genetic alteration
are associated with disease of carrot or
cancer at different stages from early to
late when we think about cancer
evolution the process is not much
different from a general evolution
process where we think of the cancer
cells at different stages to contain
and/or harbor different stats of genetic
mutations that give that give rise to
the different phenotypes including the
potential to you based around in tissues
and metastasize to distal or distal
organs is conceivable that the even for
cells with the same genetic makeup that
is they have the same genetic material
there could still be substantial
variation instead of phenotypes
including cell types for example early
stage disease could tend to be
associated with more differentiated
cells whereas more malignant aggressive
and high stage disease tend to associate
with poorly differentiated cells now in
this presentation I'm now going to talk
extensively about this phenotype
genotype relationship in the context of
term revolution is a fascinating
question instead my focus will be on the
genomic evolution in other words we try
to understand the process where the
cells acquire different genetic
alterations in the course of tumor
development in trying to understand
genome evolution from the perspective of
mutations we want to understand two
questions in particular the first
question is what is the spectrum of
genetic diversity in other words we try
to understand what kind of genetic
alterations can arise in the progeny
population even if the all of the
progeny cells started from a single
ancestor cell on top of that we are also
interested in understanding how old
operations arise in other words what is
a possible trajectory from a single
Nestor's though into one of the terminal
state it is helpful to make some
distinctions about different types of
genomic alterations that can arise one
of them I call local burns which include
both things simple base substitutions as
drawn here as an ATT change as well as
inversion divisions of one or multiple
nucleotides in contrast to local burns
another group of variants are known as
structural alterations or structural
burns structural variants do not change
individual nucleotides rather they
change or alter the organization of
large chunks of DNA including generating
these deletions or insertions of large
chunks of DNA kilobases or mega bases
long
generating duplications inversions or
transpositions and finally but also very
frequently in cancer meaning two
translocations sometimes between
different chromosomes to give you a
snapshot of the complexity of structural
operations that can appear in cancer
genomes I'm showing you for non
representative examples of cancer
genomes sample from the literature on a
very top left corner you can see one as
a genome especially consisting of a
single set of every chromosome
whereas next to it on the right there is
a cancer genome that's almost hexaploid
in other words contains about six copies
of every individual chromosome and we
also see intermediate states where you
have near liquid state or near
three-point state in addition to the
numerical operations in the number of
chromosomes there is also extensive
structural abnormalities in the
composition of individual chromosomes
shown by as the individual chromosomes
making up with different colors despite
such diversity what we know is that all
of this different cancer genomes
must have arrays
from the same as that's true state that
is essentially a deploy the human genome
that makes up all of the cells in a
human body so my lab is interested in
the question of how or what mutational
processes are happening or driving this
process when the single ancestors
they're always the diploid genome
content could evolve into this very
divergent terminal State of course in
trying to answer this question we are
not really interested in just
recapitulating individual steps of
operations that make this transition but
rather we try to understand the
underlying mutational processes and the
biological mechanisms why are we
interesting this I guess besides
intellectual curiosity one observation
connects this process to the clinical
relevance which is we often see
structural alterations that arise in the
same time when a disease transits from
low-grade or more more benign disease
into high-grade or invasive or Matassa
metastatic disease exactly how the
generation of chromosomal alterations
can be related or contribute to
transition from pre cancer - cancer is
unknown but we think that by
understanding how these alterations
arise we can learn or gain insight new
insight into the transition and which
may help us find better biomarkers to
predict disease progression as well as
uncover new vulnerabilities associated
with either a disease so my presentation
today will focus on the evolution of
cancer genomes and in particular the
evolution of structure operations in a
cancer genome before we talk about our
work on this on this understanding of
mechanism let's first review what are
the causes that can lead to Petra genome
instability there has been
a lot of work into the biology and
molecular biology generating insight on
what causes genome instability people
have already attributed causes such as
defective DNA repair including effective
error correction during DNA replication
the generation of replication expressed
disruption of DNA damage response
defective spindle assembly checkpoint
which can be too of chromosome
missegregation during cell division
telomere crisis and start division
errors how exactly can this one or
multiple mechanisms listed here
contribute the genome instability is
still not completely understood now in
my country today I actually want to talk
about one simple mechanism that could
contribute to genome instability which
is unstable chromosomes unstable
chromosomes can result from one of
multiple mechanisms including some of
the causes listed on a previous slide to
common path leading to unstable
chromosomes are shown here the top one
is known as telomere attrition we know
that a linear chromosome consists of a
centromere shown as the red girl in the
middle and two tumors which protect the
naked ends on a chromosome as cells
divide the telomeres get shorter and
shorter or H division and when telomeres
get critical is short it can be deep
protected and exposed a naked DNA and
this is known as a and the naked DNA end
is unstable because of all the DNA
repair pathways that would try to join
naked DNA and when the two Mears gets
critically short cells can undergo a
catastrophe known as chill Mir crisis
another
simple mechanism that can generate
unstable chromosomes is reciprocal
translocation think about a scenario
where two double strand DNA breaks were
generated on two different coral
and the two chromosomes underwent an
exchange of genetic material known as
the reciprocal translocation now there
are two possible ways that the two
double strand breaks can be joined
between the two chromosomes shown on top
is the outcome when the two breaks are
joined in a way such that the resulting
translocated chromosomes are still
stable meaning each chromosome has the
centromere with two telomeres except
that the partners have been swamped now
there is another possibility which means
that which which generates the outcome
that the two terminal segments are
joined and the two eccentric or two fact
two chromosomal pieces with centromeres
are joined together in this case the
reciprocal translocation creates an
eccentric fragment and a die centric
chromosome as we will be shown later
the dissection chromosome is unstable
and can lead to the generation of two
broken chromatids during cell division
the evolution of broken chromatids was
perhaps the first form of genome
evolution being observed in eukaryotes
in fact it was being observed before we
even know what chromosome was made of
Barbara McClintock first made an
observation that the generation of
broken chromatids can lead to formation
of anaphase bridges during cell division
and the bridges can persist and the
generation of bridges which which be
broken during cell division can lead to
the formation of a new bridge in
subsequent mitosis this creates a
pattern known as wreckage fusion
recycles this slide summarizes the
different steps of a breakage during per
cycle the first step is the generation
of an eccentric chromosome you can see
the two centromeres are are the two
chromosomes with centromeres are
connected at the end and mitosis the two
statue mirrors are being poured to other
side of the spindle
and two different daughter cells at some
point the chromatid bridge the
chromosome bridge which connects the two
daughter cells will be broken resulting
in two broken chromatids in each
individual daughter's down the broken
chromatid can be replicated now the
broken end is replicated as well the
broken ends can then join with the
broken in the system the replicated
sister chromatid created an creating a
new by central chromosome out of the
fusion known as the fusion event now the
new dye centric chromosome can undergo a
new round of bridge formation and
breakage event and the cycle can and can
keep going which makes the British
fusion pre cycles as you can see the
first channel in zeros generation went
up when the isometric chromosome was
formed nothing really happens by
generation one the two daughter cells
would have different genetic makeup one
daughter cell had a loss of terminal
statements and another daughter cell had
a gain of the terminal segment each
round of breakage children bridge cycle
would create a two daughter cells with
different genotypes one was a gain of
the terminal fragment the other was a
loss and you can see that market Inlet
marks by number one here one daughter
cell can acquire the terminal gains over
consecutive cycles and the outcome of
that is gene amplification shown on this
slide is an example of urban
amplification which is the frequent
oncogenic event in breast cancer in this
case it has been inferred that the
herbage olt come follows the pattern of
a British mutant priest icon now this is
the terminal stage of the genome and we
do not really know for sure how exactly
this amplification arose and the topic
of my presentation today in my
presentation today I would like to we
are trying to combine experimental in
vitro experimental system with single
cell sequencing to try to gain more
insight into how this process into how
this process
happens and including how the uncle
genic applications can be generated so
general framework of analysis is the
following we started off from Estelle
where we can engineer this abnormality
in this case abnormality is by
assumption chromosome of bridge
connecting the two daughter cells as the
two daughter cells progressed through
the cells that progress to the cell
cycle the bridge gets broken and then as
the Stealth we can either harvest the
cells to sequence them to understand the
genetic mutation outcome of bridge
resolution as well as we can let Estelle
scroll further into more progeny
populations and then do the sequencing
there to figure out the long-term
consequence evolution consequences of
bridge resolution I should mention that
this work is a combination of two
experiment two experimental and
analytical approaches on the Left it's
done primarily by lacks our imaging and
on a ride is done with single-cell
sequencing and this is a carry out by a
bunch of talented postdoctoral fellows
and research scientist shown here and
this is a project that we work closely
with David Palmas lab in Donna Farber
Cancer Institute but let's first talk
about how we generate chromosomal
bridges or broken chromatin the most
specific way of generating a broken
chromatid is to introduce a specific DNA
double strand break in this case we have
introduced the double strand break using
CRISPR guided cos 9 activity by
generating breaks when Estelle was in
the g2 star cycle phase we can create
two breaks on a sister chromatid that a
certain chance the two sister chromatids
confused at a break ends rather than
form rather than joining the terminal
segment creating a die centric
chromosome the eccentric chromosome
would not be sensed until the star
undergoes mitosis and the two central
when a two centromeres are being poured
into opposite daughter cells we watch
for the resolution
of the bridge by centric bridges is
actually obsession of an essential
bridge between the two dollar cells and
then we take or harvest the two daughter
cells or the progeny of this two
daughter cells and then do singles there
or bulk whole genome sequencing to
understand the genetic outcome now let's
look at what happens in the first
generation that is we start with a cell
and let us divide into two daughter
cells connected by a chromosomal bridge
and wait for the bridge to resolve and
then sequence the two daughter cells
separately schematically this is shown
here in the dice n trick chromosomal
bridge we don't expect the break to be
exactly symmetric between the two
centromeres if the break is not
happening exactly in the middle of the
chromosome you would imagine that one
daughter cell would inherit a broken
Croton with less and less material
whereas the other daughter cell would
inherit the chromosome the broken
chromatid with more material in other
words one daughter still has a terminal
loss and the other daughter still has a
reciprocal terminal game and indeed this
is what we see from the single cell
sequencing data shown here are the real
sequencing data of in this case the only
only chromosome that we inferred to be
the bridge chromosome and the grey dots
showed the DNA copy number of the
particular allele that was being
affected or or the particular chromatid
that it was in a bridge and you can see
that in daughter 1a there is the
terminal DNA lost the copy number goes
from 1 to 0 that is a competent by a
reciprocal game in daughter 1 B at the
same segment
exactly as we had expected so that is
simple enough in one generation we see
me terminal gain and terminal loss what
happens in a second generation so we
went on the lettuce cells divide again
in this case giving rise to four
grandchildren of course we won't be able
to take their the the we take the cells
or the mother cells all describe
daughters for sequencing those we let us
down to by nonetheless we can easily
infer two kindred relationships between
these four cells you can see that the
top two cells granddaughter cells both
have terminal games whereas the bottom
two cells each has criminal laws looking
more closely you would see the minnow
two cells share a break end just as we
see in a two cell stage and we infer the
breakpoint to be the red line shown as
the red line which is exactly where the
reciprocal gay and lost between the
minnow two cells now we notice that if
you look at the top style and the bottom
cell the game segment in the top cell
and the last that went in the bottom
cell both spend a larger genomic
territory and what we find the
explanation for this observation is that
the bridge chromatin is not fully
replicated so here is the schematic view
of missed this explanation so the two
sister chromatid underwear the first
stop division there's part of the
chromatin was in the british this part
of the bridge was not replicated even
though the rest of the two chromatids
are both replicated completely now as
the as the ridge was resolved generated
the $2 to grand on ourselves from each
side this part this middle part of the
bridge chromatin was not replicated and
is only inherited by one granddaughter
from each side whereas the other two
granddaughter do not inherit any piece
of the bridge chromatin and that
explains the pattern of mass of DNA
material in the in the bridge because of
lack of dinner application again we
learned that the british fusion recycle
is not exactly as it was described in
the original model because the lack of
DNA replication of the british chromatin
implies that over man
generations chromosomes in the bridge
would be gradually lost over the
population we took one step further in
this case we grow the donor cell which
inherited a broken chromatid into a
clonal population we want to look at
what happens in this coma population
shown here is the bulk average DNA copy
number of one such colon population
where we have engineered a broken
chromatid on chromosome four and you can
see the DNA copy number of two different
homologs
of chromosome four shown here in red and
blue in particular we recognize that a
lot of genetic alterations or copy
number alterations here are obvious
evidence on the 4pr and we we think that
was because the break was engineered at
a team america side of the chromosome
and that resulted in the generation of
these operations both on the red and the
blue now the generation of the break was
not a little specific therefore we are
not surprised that general the broken
chromatid could actually be generated on
both hormones and resulting in the
accumulation of operations in both of
them now one feature I want to emphasize
is that if you look at a DNA copy number
of the blue or the red hemorrhage
normally for one cell with a single or
those homologs you will be expected to
expect to see in an integer DNA copy
number of either the red or the blue
allele here you don't see integer code
number in fact the DNA copy number is
almost always between integer states and
in our importation for that instead of
the cell having non integer number of
molecules
it's rather implies that the population
of cells consist of different color
populations and the different colon
populations might have different copy
number states of this difference of the
both the red and the blue
so we decided to dig deeper into this to
resolve this we took individual cells
from the progeny population grow this
individual cells into a clone and
performed again also genome sequencing
to look at a DNA copy number
the results are schematically shown on
the right the blue bar represents the
presence of the blue homolog whereas the
absence of the blue reflects the loss of
the blue homolog in the population on
top in the bottom we also see that the
blue homolog is overwhelmingly lost from
every individual cell that has been
sequenced now what makes this even more
interesting was that the red homolog
underwent segmental gains but different
patterns of segmental gains in
population above and populations below
separated by the solid black line all of
the cells on top share the same pattern
of blue Omaha in terms of the ending
copy number whereas the cells in the
bottom panel showed bearing copy number
states of the red homolog most
importantly the great points or
segmental break points of the copy
number changes in the top population and
the bottom population are totally
distinct
we can perform heuristic clustering of
the individual cells based on a copy
number States and shown here is the
heuristic phylogeny because of the the
scarcity due to the scarcity of copy
number events we will not be we will not
be entirely confident about the progeny
about a phylogeny of the different cells
but we can recognize at least there are
two main branches the top branch showing
this oshare this red copy number stays
in the in draw in a right angle
- rectangle and the bottom population
show different copy number states of the
red homologue to show you how this how
made an interest on the real data this
slide 22 shows the original sequencing
data of DNA copy number of the
and a blue homolog with the schematic
view of the segmental copy number states
drawn below the sequencing data as you
can see that all of the different cells
share as common ancestral breakpoints
and the red homolog on the tumeric side
very close to the telomere but
individual cells follow different
evolutionary trajectories and acquire
very different patterns of segmental
gains of the red homolog I've marked the
private breakpoint segmental break when
using green green vertical lines and we
occasionally can see shared breakpoints
between different singles that all the
cones shown here as the magenta vertical
line one mechanism that we can gain
further insight into the evolutionary
trajectory is to use the pattern of
chromosome rearrangements that we detect
in the difference across the chromosomal
rearrangement tells us how different
gain segments are being joined together
in interest of time I'm now going to go
deep I'm not going to go to the detail
of how we use the rearrange
rearrangement pattern to infer the
phylogeny but showing simply show you
the result of our reconstruction of the
different events in the course of
evolution or example the first event
marks the initial ancestral break until
America that is accompanied by a
internal translocation followed by a
translocation to come from 14 after that
event the two branches started off doing
their on different evolutionary
trajectory and acquire different
alterations I want to emphasize that
even though we only have information
about the genotypes being the progeny
cells in a terminal state by looking at
the relationship between this progeny
cells and constructing a phylogeny tree
that allows us to infer the trajectory
of evolution shown here as the dashed
arrows
in order to gain further resolution into
the amount degree of genetic diversity
in a population we further perform a
single cell profiling in this case we
selected hundreds of cells from the
progeny population and profile their DNA
copy number using a recent essay
developed by timox genomics which allows
us to interrogate DNA copy number of of
hundreds of single cells in a parallel
fashion shown here is the in a copy
number he map of five hundred cells of
chromosome four so the each row here
corresponds to the DNA copy number and
one mega base bends on chromosome four
in the next slide we zoom in into the
region of the pea arm where we see the
most genetic variation and diversity
between the different copy number states
and I highlighted the different copy
number States we have previously
detected in the sub normal population
and their correspondence in the single
cell profiling again we can see the
consistency between the selected
standpoint from single cell forming
which will only allow us to stop for a
limited number of individual cells
genome genomes and the single cell
profiling which tremendously expands the
resolution into status into a stem cell
variability in the genotype now this is
one sample that already gives us a lot
of insight into the amount of genetic
variation that can arise from a single
ancestral break in the next example I'm
going to show you a stamp of where the
evolution takes a different term
again let's start from the population
level the bulk average in a copy number
in the population of cells so here on
top is the average DNA copy number of
the red and the blue homolog and blow up
of the p arm is shown in the bottom if
you look at the readily we can see
there's a lot of dots that oscillates
between copy number one and
approximately [ __ ] number two
essentially reflecting Sacramento
amplifications or stem went to loss
whereas if you look at the blue allele
it shows largely a loss between with an
average population copy number between
zero and one let's first look at a blue
allele again we take single cells from
the progeny population grow them into
stock lungs and then the whole genome
sequencing to look at the DNA copy
number in a stock crop in the bulk we
see this average copy number between
zero and one when we look at individual
cells however we see this very striking
pattern that there's an extensive
variability between the different cells
in term in their DNA copy number of the
blue allele in particular we see there
is some cell with criminal laws and that
last it's bigger in other cell in other
cells in the same population and we
speculate that this very matter of DNA
terminal DNA loss could reflect some
ongoing evolution in the progeny
population in other words this could
reflect some ongoing or continues
instability in the progeny population
now there are also of course those with
stable single copy copy state of the
blue leo and the cells that have lost
all of the PR that are also stable but
in between these two stable states we
see the spectrum of variation from very
small terminal loss to a large amount of
our level loss now when we turn to the
red allele as I mentioned earlier there
are segmental gains shown as the dots
above the baseline copy number of f1 and
then you can also see segmental
interspersed loss in on the left
where the large chromosomal segments
that is having copy number two
occasionally drops in Oconomowoc well we
look at individual sub stop cones each
of them develop each of them grown from
a single cell again we see a lot of
variability between these individual
cells often restricted to a particular
region in the genome highlighted here
between some of the highlighted here
between the blue lines in particular you
will recognize there are focal regions
that are preserved in some styles but
masked in other cells between 30 and 40
mega bases we went out to perform single
stop profiling of the same population
and again shown here is the P on copy
number stage from single style copy
under profiling that is the consistent
with what we see from the ball data and
also verifying what we see from the
single cell sub well now on splice 30
I'm showing you another example that
showed very similar feature as what we
just saw in the previous sample for the
blue allele and in this case we see that
both the red homologue and the blue
homolog shows this varying DNA copy
number that is non constant between
different cells and also that's
highlighted with the sine stick sign
line on the bottom I think there's
instead of a single sharp transition
between different copy number states
it's a gradual slope between two
different copy number states reflecting
with extensive variation in this
population of cells so to summarize on
this part of outcome of copy number
alterations generated by a single broken
chromatid what we have seen is in the
first generation the two daughter cells
show this reciprocal terminal loss and
gang now the lost can persist into many
generations eventually terminate
at the end of the centromere this could
lead to your arm levels on the other
side the game can be to further
segmental gains including including
additional translocation which would
result in a stable or stabilize the
unstable chromosome and leading to
translocations both within the same
chromosome as well as involving other
chromosomes what is intriguing is that
if one in one of the samples I showed
previously
there's also focal amplifications that
started to develop in at least a
Stockholm of population of cells
so what could contribute or what
mechanisms are generating the focal
amplifications let's come back to this
down home again in this sample we show
that there are pieces or small segments
between 30 and 40 mega bases the small
segments of the red allele that seem to
undergo dynamic evolution and and
develop enough a high level
amplification in some of us think
ourselves the ability to trace our
chromosome rearrangements help us
understand how exactly these fragments
are generated if you look at a very top
population the rearrangement we detected
that join the different copy number
segments are shown above the Cotner quad
so here the black arcs represent joins
between different segments and the arc
pointing outward reflects joins in one
orientation and arcs pointing downwards
reflects joins of the other orientation
I want to pay attention to this red arc
on the right which is also thicker than
the black lines when we zoom into this
single translocation what we see is that
the translocation is not simply formed
between the two ends as shown here
instead the translocation junction
involves multiple tiny segments being
hijacked across multiple spots across
the genome
you can see this this and this the
single event is being represented as
this wiring pattern if you follow you
the end from the from the the very the
far right you walk the different curves
all of this curve jump back and forth
eventually land at the terminal point
that was shown as the other end in the
top so this complex we believe this
complex rearrangement actually might
play a role in generating the focal
amplifications by putting all of this
short fragments together indeed as we
look at the generation of translocations
from even the first generation or for
most cases we see the break of the
chromosome or a chromatid was
accompanied by a simple translocation
but also in a small fraction of cases we
see that the breakage of the chromatid
was the confident by very complex
pattern of recombination events so here
I think who the three examples where the
black curves and the magenta vertical
lines represent translocations near the
side of breakage that resulted from the
initial formation of a dye centric
chromosome bridge so we believe that the
formation of complex chromosome
rearrangements including potentially the
generation of broken many broken pieces
of the chromatid resolving from
chromosomal bridge resolution
contributes to the generation of focal
amplification event exactly mechanism
still remains not all not completely
clear and we're working to resolve the
detail of how this process could happen
one thing that I didn't have time to get
into detail is we also observe that when
multiple chromosomes were involved in
chromosomal bridges for example when
three chromosomes were both formed by
essentially chromosomes and still
and yes they broken the brigands from
the different chromosomes can join
together to form this chain between
different chromosomes this pattern was
sometimes known as complexity which is
one different form of complex comes on
the rear entrance to summarize on this
part we have talked about the wide
spectrum of genomic alterations that can
result from a single cell division
abnormality known as the chromosome of
bridge now we know there are many other
kinds of star division errors including
multipolar by ptosis lagging chromosome
and you can see them across the bridge
of the bridge protein shown in
ingredients showed on top and formation
of a micro nucleus previously we have
shown that eating a problem in the micro
nucleus can undergo tremendous
catastrophe essentially resulting in a
fragmentation of the chromatid and being
distributed into two daughter cells and
this generates a mutational pattern
known as chromothripsis or fragmentation
of a chromosome that was frequently seen
in the cancer genome now the work I've
presented to you here showed that the
generation of chromosomal bridges can
potentially create something similar to
a micro nucleus except that because the
bridge chromatin was more localized to a
segment in the chromosome so it could
result in this polarization that's
restricted to a more more localized the
region in the chromosome and we believe
that the generation of abnormal nuclear
structures such as chromosomal bridges
and micro nuclei might play an important
role in generating and genetic genetic
alterations now in remaining on this
talk I want to share with you a slightly
different story which is on the other
end of
understand genome evolution from in the
context of tumor development in this
case we try to study the evolution of
genomic alterations in the process of
either progression from parrot esophagus
which is a known pre malignant condition
of esophageal adenocarcinoma to a
stoppage of cancer
this work is done in collaboration with
dr. Adam bass web at their father with
master who's not a UCSF and a
postdoctoral fellow in Adams champa so
what do we know about the formation of
esophageal adenocarcinoma from Barrett's
esophagus is that genome instability
plays an important role in this process
this is shown here is a schematic
diagram from a 2015 a genetics paper
from an embassador showing the two
different pathways that aberrant
esophagus could progress to invasive
valinor carcinoma and in fact there are
two different pathways one of them
involves a peculiar step known as whole
genome duplication when itself fails
telekinesis another step doesn't involve
function of duplication but involves
loss of tumor suppressors including P 16
SDK and tp53 that would essentially
unleash a firestorm of genome evolution
now what we have done is we have looked
at we have harvested tissue from
different stages in the course of
progression from buried esophagus to
establish your adenocarcinoma and
profile the copy number of miss
different lesions so it's less 42 I'm
showing you one example where we are
comparing the copy number evolution in
this case of one particular chromosome
which is chromosome 18 in five different
these tissues from Paris esophagus low
grade dysplasia Hydra displeasure to
cancer what you can see here
is the Baroness topic is it's already
obvious that by the way the the finger
here shown on a ride are a living DNA
copy number so what you can see here is
even in the birth a stop against lesion
you can already see segments of DNA loss
affecting a big chunk of the chromosome
18 arm as we see as we as we go down and
and look through the local dysplasias we
started seeing more events including
focal amplifications that arise next to
terminal loss this distant past in the
Mowbray dysplasia
as well as in high-grade dysplasia now
remarkably some of these focal
amplifications are shared for example
between low grade dysplasia - and
high-grade dysplasia but other there are
other complications that are private to
individual lesions for example in local
dysplasia one and low-grade displeasure
to there are focal gains in in in this
case even including known cancer genes
that are lost or not observed in high
grade dysplasia now finally when we go
to a salvage yard on carcinoma which is
supposedly the most malignant disease we
actually don't see any sign of the
author chromosome at all in fact we
infer that the chromosome that has
undergone such dynamic evolution in low
grade of high-grade dysplasia is
completely lost in a you know personal a
slide for is three I'm showing you
another example again this is listening
who samples from the same patient with
burned esophagus low grade dysplasia
hybrid dysplasia and its Australian or
carcinoma in this case I'm showing you
the evolution on chromosome 17 we can
recognize there is a very high-level
focal amplification on chromosome 17
that's obvious from the low in both the
low-grade is equation number two and
esophageal adenocarcinoma that includes
both are B to G and the star 3 as
hierarchy
hired here now when you look at the
early stage lesions including local
displeasure one and a high grade
dysplasia you can already see some
activity some copy number alterations
around the same region that is somehow
shared between the local displeasure
water highway dysplasia but distinct
from low grade dysplasia - and they stop
your adenocarcinoma moreover when you
compare the local displeasure to and an
adenocarcinoma you see very similar DNA
copy number patterns including extensive
segmental copy number changes both
gained and lost determinants
next-to-last
to the region of focal amplification so
what this model suggests is that even
though we generally think of high-grade
or invasive disease as the stamp who is
the most copy number alterations always
the highest level of genome instability
in fact even in some of the early stage
lesions such events are already
happening and the reason that we have
not seen this perhaps is because we
often do both DNA sequencing and
sometimes when the harvest of the sample
when the sample we harvested is not pure
enough we're not going to be able to
detect a stop call or population of
cells that already have acquired such
alterations so to test this we have
performed a single cell DNA sequencing
on one patient a different patient from
what was shown in the previous two
slides so in this patient we profiled
about 60 cells from a high-grade
dysplasia that was by Ofsted by a
pathologist and we assayed their DNA
copy number so each cell is shown in a
column and each row represents a single
chromosome arm so from top to bottom
it's from the one or where's the curse
of why and each each column corresponds
to a single cell so to the left you see
a large population of cells that remain
mostly diploid except for
occasional walls of crimson wire which
is a frequent event in male patients
we then see cells with some level of
operation most most frequently on
chromosome 17 P where the well-known
tumor suppressor chip industry is
located and that is in the hypo diploid
population as we get to the right we
start to see more and more copy number
alterations and we infer the population
of cells which have become mostly
tetraploid which means all the DNA each
chromosome has doubled its copy number
and lastly we see cells which has
extensive unlevel and whole chromosome
copy number changes they are mostly
unemployed meaning they don't have a
even chromosome paths for different
chromosomes in particular in to
unemployed cells we observed a focal
amplification the RB 2 + / B 2 locus
that's next to a terminal that's next to
a large segmental amplification in the
same sample we also see lost loss of
heterozygosity
on the 17p arm that was presumably
related to chromosome others presumably
related to t3 inactivation so what this
data showed us is that the dynamic
evolution of an unstable genome might
have already occurred in high-grade
dysplasia and some cells after they have
acquired hallmark events in this case
the application of a virtual locust
would have the potential to develop into
more malignant and invasive disease in
fact the inactivation of tumor
suppressors chip industry and p16
will enable the self to tolerate this
ongoing genome evolution instability and
even if this cell doesn't evolve to
become cancer is there's a good chance
that some of the progeny populations
descended from this cell would have a
potential to do so so with that I want
to conclude my presentation for today
with a quick summary in the first part
of my presentation I hope I've convinced
you
that even by generating a single broken
chromosome creating a single unstable
chromosome can lead to of our store of
genome evolution and mutagenesis this
can give rise to large terminal DNA loss
generate segments of gains complex
rearrangements including a formation of
focal amplifications although now shown
here we believe the generation of
segmental and vocal alterations is often
related to abnormal nuclear structures
such as chromatin bridges and micro
nuclei which can potentially generate
fragmentation of the chromatin ins in
structures one I think profound
implication of this result is that
chromosomal instability even though it
started off with one single unbroken one
single unstable chromosome can lead to
extensive genetic diversity and
continuous evolution in the progeny
population in fact even when we sample
as few as 20 to 30 seconds or 20 to 30
cells that development do stop clonal
population they often show extensive
variation in the DNA copy number finally
we think that a transition from
precancerous lesions to cancer can be
very dynamic and genome instability by
play an important role in generating
diversity of genotypes that would
provide rush Wharram cells that can be
selected for under certain tissue
context thank you for your attention